quick one the diver ceo live my live
show my live reincarnation of this
podcast is coming on tour and it's
coming to a city near you there's a link
in the description below put your email
address in and i will email you when
tickets go on sale
can't wait to see you
you know when you have that kind of
experience early you grow up very fast
and you know what's important and you
prioritize so
another deep question is a depression
yeah okay so did you feel like a bit of
a fraud no no i totally thought i knew
what i was doing people don't do that
they don't when you're 20.
people came back madonna and uma thurman
and oprah
[Music]
marcia kilgore
i can't actually believe
what you're about to hear i can't
actually believe that one human being
could have achieved that many successful
business exits back-to-back she's built
companies like soap and glory like bliss
beauty pie which she's building at the
moment and these companies have sold for
tens and hundreds of millions they've
made hundreds of millions in annual
revenue and the remarkable thing is
she's not just done it once she's not
just done it twice
not three times not four times she's
done it five
times and i sat here with her trying to
figure out why her what was it about
marcia that made her achieve such
tremendous things in her life and i
think we finally got there i think we
finally found the answer and is it
something that you can replicate
a lot of it is and i think that's what
makes this podcast today so interesting
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
dyer of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
there is so much that makes you unique
so much and sometimes i think i think
i'm guilty of this to some degree too we
don't always see ourselves as being
unique because we're inside of our minds
and we're you know we're behaving in the
way that feels natural to us but when i
look at your your story and the
decisions you've made since you were
very very young it's so clear to me that
there's something so different about
many things that are so different about
you and i want to kind of get to the
root of that what is the foundation of
that difference what was it what was the
culture and the experience that created
the person you went on to become for the
following you know
wow that's starting with a very very
deep question isn't it it is yeah yeah i
mean i think that um i grew up in a very
small town and a small city and canada
at that time was you know relatively
simple
and i always had a hunger to learn more
and read more and find out more and kind
of knew that i didn't really fit in in a
small city
so very early on i kind of started to
think well what can i do and how can i
get out of here but i didn't have much
guidance so my father died early and my
mom was not necessarily someone who
would help me you know look at
universities for instance or say hey you
should really your grades are really
great why don't you study and do this or
that because she had never done it
herself
so she um no one really in my family
guided me and at that point there
weren't really university counselors or
anyone
doing that job in in high schools at
least in in canada so i think for me i
realized quite early probably when i was
a teenager that i just needed more
stimulation and i needed more than what
was there
just to you know feel fulfilled and and
keep my curiosity going those teenage
years
you have a lot of experiences and
apparently what happens during your
teenage years because your brain is
forming in a very different way and it's
starting to sort of solidify right and
those kinds of experience really stick
with you through your whole life and i
remember having several part-time jobs
when i was a teenager um all you know
simultaneously while going to high
school and never really finding a job
where i thought that the person in
charge of the business was doing it well
so
i worked at a gym for instance and
always thought they could do it so much
better if they were just doing this that
and the other thing i taught aerobics
classes and i thought aerobics was so
boring the way it was done and tried to
do it you know in a very different way
so it was more fun for the people who
came
and just always trying to improve the
experience because i was in quite a
mediocre
setting lovely setting but you know very
average very uh you know middle canada
um and so that was probably a bit of the
a bit of the stimulation
on that point though that that sort of
philosophy or even the thought that you
could make something better
that's that's a point of difference a
lot of people don't have where did where
did that come from in you so early that
if something isn't good enough that you
had the power within yourself to do
something about it because i think most
people will go through life just
accepting things as they are
that would be just terribly depressing
wouldn't it
i guess if you
can connect the dots and see your way to
something that might be more elevating
for your mind and then for others and
make something a little bit more fun
you can go deep into the childhood stuff
right and just think about i mean there
were situations in my childhood and it
happens to a lot of people so i'm my you
know by no means unique in this respect
but where for instance and this would
probably be more girls than boys but at
some point in every girl's existence in
school you become the unpopular one
how you feel maybe so much of an
outsider when suddenly you're out and
how painful that can be i think probably
in my experience when i was suddenly not
cool anymore
probably was really painful for me
because i also feel things quite acutely
so trying also to think well if other
people feel left out how can you make
them feel
like they're more a part of something
and so most of the businesses that i
create are are very democratic um bliss
even which was my spa that i created in
in new york i mean we had everybody
coming in from like madonna and uma
thurman and oprah right but then the
12 year old kids who had chronic acne
and you know their moms would bring them
in to have facials we treated everybody
exactly the same way
um i think one of my favorite memories
from that was when i was
actually giving a facial to one of these
12 year old kids that her mom had
brought her from boston and uma thurman
was in the locker room at the same time
and helped her open her locker so she
comes into my treatment room and goes
oh my therma just help me unlock my
locker it was so cute because you know
everybody was the same and that makes me
feel
great i think probably some of that
experience as a child not feeling equal
being left out maybe a little bit we we
after my father passed away we were not
necessarily poor or you know but not
so certainly not comfortable in any way
shape or form um at one point we moved
back to a small town and we kind of
lived on the wrong side of the tracks if
there was a wrong side of the tracks we
lived on the wrong side of the tracks in
this very small town where my mother's
family was from so you kind of felt like
you weren't quite as good as everyone
else but that wasn't fair
and so
very likely the idea of this
democratization of the good stuff is
probably comes from that but i'm sure
you could grab any therapist anywhere
and they would give you a different
version of it the passing of your father
seems to be quite a poignant point you
you seem to refer to it as like before
and after how life was somewhat
different
and um after your father passed away um
the requirement for you to develop like
a real sense of independence seems to
sort of really come through yeah i think
i read it that you got you had three
part-time jobs at one point yeah yeah
well i had to i mean my mother was a
secretary right so she didn't have a you
know huge income i
at the time i was probably 11 right so i
didn't ask her hey do we have any money
in the bank you don't really ask those
kinds of questions after the the death
of uh
of your parent um but i assumed just
from
the way that my mother you know acted
that we weren't exactly stable or you
know financially well-off so
being i think the youngest but yet
potentially the most responsible of the
three um sisters i kind of felt like i
had to help and maybe help in order for
her to feel
better herself
have you ever watched jim carrey he
actually talks about i mean of course
you've watched jim carrey but there's an
interview that he gives where he talks
about his mother actually suffered from
tremendous depression
and he learned to be funny
because he wanted her to laugh
and he wanted to see her feel good and i
know there is something about okay
i'm gonna
have a paper route and i'm gonna you
know be a personal trainer or teach
aerobics and i'm gonna work as a
waitress even though i'm not necessarily
old enough to serve alcohol in this
establishment
whatever it was i would just do it
because i want i wanted to take the
stress off of her
i didn't want her to think if i wanted
you know a car or
whatever it was that she was going to
have to pay for it because i knew it was
already quite stressful for her to just
pay the rent so i think you know you
just do whatever is expected of you and
and
it's fine right it's great it gives it's
a skill it's like a gift in a way you
can look at it and just think well i
developed that skill from ten thousand
hours of practice maybe uh over a year
or two and uh it was never hard for me
to work again you mentioned the gym
though
personal training oh yeah so when i
moved to new york
it's a long story but i then moved to
new york when i was 18 after
my 12th grade and i got accepted to
columbia university and i was supposed
to go but i didn't have
any money and my sister who lived in new
york said i'll help you out with your
tuition but then she had a little snafu
with her income that year it was like a
tax thing or whatever you know again no
big deal and so i was in new york and i
had no
no money to go to university and it was
too late because i was canadian to get a
foreign student loan
so i decided to use the only skill that
i had when i was and i know you can tell
this about me but i was a bodybuilder
i know it's kind of hard to see now
but
i was i was like a middleweight
bodybuilding champion when i was a
teenager you know between the three
part-time jobs i would then go to the
gym at night and you know where did that
come from because that's that is a that
takes a degree of dare i say it
dedication to say the least yeah it was
it was random i think it was again my
sister started dating this guy whose
brother owned a bodybuilding gym
and he said to me hey you should come
down to the gym because i was a long
distance runner and you know just to
kind of let off steam i think i just
love to always go running
and so he said oh you should come down
miss canada at the time like miss canada
lightweight or featherweight or whatever
she she worked out there and so she put
me through the paces and gave me a
routine and all this kind of stuff and i
just went because it was something to do
but even then though a lot of people go
to the gym they train whatever two days
three days a week for you to have gone
from just walking in the door to
becoming a
like a junior bodybuilding champion or
something you know i suppose again if
you like had a therapist come in and say
oh why would you do that it's probably
to give some kind of semblance control
and the ability to achieve something
you know to my life which at the time
i'm a teenager in a high school
in the middle of saskatchewan
school was not so hard for me yeah
so what else am i going to do a sense of
like purpose i guess and yeah and and to
have that discipline you also have
control right so if you can control your
body
then you could probably control other
things if you can achieve things with
seeing how far you can take it then you
know it just adds to the i guess the the
challenge this is the video you like a
bit of a challenge i do i love challenge
i also really love working out and i'm i
will go to the gym every single day and
i i you know what it was i had a
i sat here with a entrepreneur and she
um is very well known she got millions
of followers online for bit for
basically being a bodybuilder she
describes herself as a bodybuilder she
doesn't
you know she's a very lean bodybuilder
let's say but um
and she told me that when she was in
school she was outcasted a little bit
and she would eat her like lunch in the
the toilets her name's chrissy chella um
and her her going to the gym was in some
respects an escape from all of that it
was like
her way of yeah
i think building herself controlling
building herself just yeah if you think
about physically what's happening right
she's building herself back up yeah yeah
and when you start talking about sort of
being excluded from the the cool kids
and stuff and then
that your bodybuilding became a big sort
of you know feature in your life at that
age i wondered if there was a link or
um because it is an extreme thing it
requires a
a level of persistence in a an okayness
with being uncomfortable
physically uncomfortable
you know what the gym was also full of
adults
and i think i was a young adult so i
probably had more of a mindset of an
adult early i'm not i'm not like the
most intelligent human being on you know
on the earth but i'm probably
slightly more
intellectual than
most of the people that i was in school
with
so i found my friends in a an
environment where there were people
working out and being healthy and just
older
and so i think that probably had
something to do with it too you had
people to talk to there that you could
kind of
connect to versus the teenagers who
maybe were going through their teenage
things i'd say also and i've had this
conversation with you know if you've
experienced a death in your family early
or if you've had a parent or a sibling
who's
uh you know chronically ill or
handicapped you see life in a very
different way right so if your father
dies when you're 11
and you're in a high school with
a group of girls and they're all very
catty and you just think
really
you're not going there it's not
interesting to be part of that kind of
crowd you don't want to talk about those
kinds of things they're not important
and you know it because you've been
through something profound very early on
so
it's hard to connect to people who
haven't
like you know when you have that kind of
experience early you grow up very fast
and you know what's important and you
prioritize so
it's hard to find anyone to relate to
if you have a bunch of teenagers who
haven't right
are you saying that you didn't fit in
you didn't think you fitted into that i
don't have any friends from high school
do you yeah okay so did you fit in i
know yeah so
yeah i probably didn't fit in and we
didn't feel like an outcast in any way
shape or form but i had not much to talk
to them about right what they were
what they wanted to talk about at that
time just wasn't that interesting to me
so whether or not i was fitting in or
not i just didn't have the same interest
i guess um
you know as as the other kids who were
maybe able to grow up at a normal
pace because of you know their normal
existence
so take me back then so you you get the
place at columbia yeah i got a place at
columbia and then it didn't work out
that year
and i thought oh maybe i'll save up and
i'll go next year but i have to here i
am in new york i have 300 right and my
mom
for i was the third of three girls and
the two uh older ones were a bit of a
handful right so
she gave me for my grade 12 graduation
present like a backpack that was also a
suitcase
and i was i was actually the really
disciplined helpful one but i think she
had just had it like by then she'd been
through the death of my dad and then my
my older sister who had moved away quite
early and then my middle sister who
you know was um
i wouldn't say complicated but she'd
been in a couple of car accidents like
it was exhausting for my mother so
by the time i was done high school i
think she was just like see ya
and i don't blame her right a single mom
three girls you must be
like up to here
so she gave me this bag and i moved and
i actually moved in with my sister who
was living in new york
and um and i needed to work because i
had to you know it was like well here i
am i'm not going back to saskatchewan
and so i had to figure out what to do
and the only skill i had at the time was
like the body
and so i got a
gym membership at this place called
better bodies which was on 19th street
between 5th and 6th
and it was the place where kind of
everybody who was anybody you know back
then like bodybuilding had started to
kind of be a thing you know everybody's
talking about arnold i think pumping
iron had kind of
maybe just come out
i mean this was way before arnold was a
governor
and um and so i went to the gym and
jean-claude van damme worked out there
and his wife gladys portuguese who was
also this famous bodybuilder and then
all the kind of cool film directors and
fashion designers when everybody went to
this gym
however they were quite new to it i had
been like bodybuilding by then for three
years or four years maybe even and so i
looked great right and so did
jean-claude and so did gladys the rest
of them
not yet
so i would have people come to me and
i'm 18 right and say hey i want to you
know i want to look like you because i
wasn't really bulky i looked like an
olympic athlete and so they wanted how i
looked yeah yeah and so i'd charge them
15 or 20 an hour and do personal
training which you know back then for an
18 year old it was a lot because minimum
wage was probably
350. so i thought oh this is amazing
and so i became a personal trainer to
you know a lot of kind of celebs and
they would then send me to their friend
and refer me to this person or that
person and so
it started out that way but i kind of
realized working in the gym for 15 bucks
an hour was not gonna pay my rent
and or anything else and probably was
not that sustainable over the long term
and i had no business skills as such but
i knew what good service was like
because with common sense you know how
you want to be treated and you know
how you would want to show up and how
you want to treat your customer and how
you try to make sure that they enjoy
their experience so that they have you
back now personal training is one of
those things where most people who need
a personal trainer hate exercise
otherwise you wouldn't really need a
personal trainer so there was a lot of
thought that went into like the i would
i guess you would talk about it now as
like a loyalty mechanic
yeah how can i get them to make sure
they don't cancel right because they
hate this otherwise i wouldn't be coming
yeah i have to make sure that this whole
experience they're just looking forward
to it
so that every you know tuesday and
thursday or whatever
i'm showing up and making my 40 bucks
otherwise i wouldn't be able to pay my
rent
um so
i think the early seeds of how do you
get someone to come back
and and how do you give services so
above and up and beyond that there's
nobody else that will try this hard
it was planted then because you learn
about
loyalty and customer attention gotta
always be pleasant
right i mean you have to be patient you
have to be totally absolutely focused on
your customer right so it was about them
it was not about me
and i think there are a lot of people
who slip into friend mode
right or start to kind of talk about
their problems it's like no one is
paying you to listen to your problems so
whether you are a personal trainer or
giving a facial or waxing somebody's
legs or whatever it is nobody wants to
hear about your stuff that's not why
they're paying right you're there to
focus on them and no one gets enough
attention maybe some people get enough
attention but most people don't get
enough attention they don't have someone
who really listens to them right all
rushing around all the time
so even to just be there doing whatever
it is you're doing taking them through
their paces running them up flights of
stairs i mean i took people jogging
right around manhattan
nine times a day i was fenced
and you went on to stop bliss yes so
tell me from running around manhattan
nine times a day running upstairs and in
the summer especially my skin got quite
bad and it had never been great
you know through my teenage years
everybody has a little bit of you know
acne etc etc but mine i'd never quite
solved it and i bought a lot of products
to try and solve it and actually
personally train somebody who worked at
one of the
hot you know skincare brands at the time
he gave me everything and nothing really
worked
and so i thought one summer
in the summer when you're a personal
trainer in new york all of your clients
generally will go to the hamptons and so
for me that was like two months without
income right no one pays you when
they're not working out
so i thought i can either go to the
hamptons and be captive in somebody's
house because you then become kind of
like people would drag you to the beach
and say oh here's my personal training
and you just it was not a good dynamic
for somebody like me who does not i mean
it's freedom i want freedom
so
i decided i found this skin care uh it
was it was like school
and i decided to take this crash course
in how to you know fix your own skin and
it was actually how to do facials but i
was taking it for myself and then i
realized i really loved it and then i
convinced my very trusting and i am so
grateful to them but personal training
clients
these were you know some a names
and they let me name joke they they let
me practice on them name like at the
time oprah
oh yeah i've had a yeah
yeah yeah yeah but when i very very
early on it was more like paul simon and
carrie fisher so i mean everybody
everybody was anybody kind of came in
and and let me do their face and it was
a real it was like a real gift to be
trusted with people who relied on their
faces for their work
right at early stage your own location
in manhattan well it started with people
coming to my
to my apartment oh okay yeah so i would
personally train people by running all
over manhattan during the day and then
at night i
because my
sister had some connections with the
modeling agent
modeling industry let's just say
she had some bookers who had some other
models who had terrible skin
and so they would send these models to
me because i was known i guess i mean i
didn't even have a reputation for
knowing what i was doing but and they
would come to my apartment in the east
village
and literally lie on the floor did you
feel like a bit of a fraud in those
early days when you were like no no i
totally thought i knew what i was doing
okay yeah because i worked so hard right
so i knew the steps of a facial and i
had never
had a facial somewhere where it was any
different than what i was doing
and i knew that i was more you know
where a normal facial would take an hour
i would spend two and a half on somebody
so i knew that if i didn't necessarily
have the best technique i was going to
try harder sure and so i'd make up for
it that way
people came back and then they sent me
all their friends and then they sent me
all their friends and then suddenly you
know it was like a social club you
couldn't get people out of the house so
i'd have to get up at 5am to go do a
personal training session with somebody
someone would have come over for a
facial at 8 o'clock at night the night
before i finished them at 10 30 and then
they'd want to chat and it was like i
got to get an office because i got to
get these people out of here we can't
because you're kind of stuck in your
apartment and it's hard to then
get the client to then go
when they're in your house there seems
to be a theme emerging here which is i
mean you only just told me about two
kind of professional pursuits the
personal training and now the
the facial business as it started um but
you're
really you seem some as to be someone
that's really remarkable at customer
experience because the fact that you
can't get them out your house
um and that your you know these personal
training clients are
you know letting me do yeah yeah letting
me experiment on them with wax and
things like that yeah yeah that's like a
really underrated thing i mean what
we're talking about there is
fundamentally like sales sales i guess
and trust yeah yeah which i think is
part of sales right like trust is a
super important part of being you know
and you and sales you know if you're
selling it sounds bad i think doesn't it
yeah because
i mean i hate the idea of sales but i
love selling yeah but i couldn't sell
something if i didn't think it was great
don't ask me to sell something i don't
love because i can't do it but if i love
something i could sell it to anybody
so
i guess it's more about aligning your
like moral conviction with whatever it
is that you are then selling do you
consider yourself a salesperson
well
would i say i'm a salesperson that's a
really hard
so without the stigma yeah just remove
the stigma well everything is sales
right exactly yeah you just have to be
look you got to be pleasant right unless
you're some kind of genius that people
need to have around
the world gets to choose who they're
interacting with
and so
if you want in in any area of your life
right if you want to have like great
team members
in your office you better be pleasant to
be around or they're not
they're not going to stay if you
want to you know meet with a an editor
or a journalist or who are they going to
write about probably the people hey yes
everybody's got an interesting story but
those who they like
are probably going to get a little
further than those who are [ __ ]
right interesting yeah do you consider
yourself a salesperson
yeah yeah yeah but without you i have
the same allergic reaction to the term
where i'm like forcing because we're not
forcing things upon people that we don't
believe in no you're helping them find
what they probably would have bought but
find the right one yeah sales is
persuasion it's body language it's
communication it's the way you know
the passion you have for what you're
talking about and and it's delivering
information in a way that helps somebody
make a choice without feeling stressed
right because generally i think if you
if you are trying to get someone to try
something right but you're
pushing it in the wrong way that isn't
aligning with what they need to
hear about it
then that is a failed
sale yeah yes because actually you
should be listening and if they don't
think you're objective right and this is
one of the things i think has been most
successful with my longest-standing
clients from my previous company was
they knew that i would come there and i
would tell them when our work was bad
yeah so i would say don't do this it's a
waste it's gonna waste your money yes
but these things here i actually think
are gonna work really well so the minute
i would say but these things here they'd
go yes yeah because they felt i was
charging the objectives
yeah which is sort of number one isn't
it it's like worse for us better for you
yeah yeah and if people feel like you're
aligned with them doing better which is
what you always should be anyway yeah
because that's just listening to the
customer and giving i mean it's so basic
right it's back to the basics of you
listen to them and you give them what
they're asking for and that's sales
actually so if you they'll tell you any
customer will tell you what they want
the customers always know what they want
though
no no definitely not right somebody said
to me and they weren't talking about
customers they were talking about buyers
at department stores so the people who
are employed by department stores to
purchase the merchandise that then get
sold on to customers and he said buyers
department store buyers are experts at
yesterday
right and to some extent it's true they
look at their data from you know before
and so of course if you look at the
world of the percentage of uh people who
are visionary enough to think about
something new that people might want
it's probably quite a small percentage
and all the rest of the people
think in a different way and you know
provide a lot of value to the world in
different ways but there are a select
few i suppose who think of the new stuff
and like that's our job
and then of course you have to get
people to come with you which is
difficult sometimes
they don't necessarily see it so you've
got to figure out how to describe it to
them whether that's by pictures or words
or
however else that's the sales part right
yeah i suppose so it's also a lot of
psychology i mean there's so many
barriers right there i mean
have you ever i mean do you read
behavioral economics
behavioral economics um yes i've read
like the psychology of money which i
think is pretty much behavioral
economics and then i i did a course on
psychology and i've most of my books and
there are psychology books but there's
so many fascinating books like by dan
ariely or richard thaler or daniel
kahneman
they they won you know nobel prizes for
the behavioral economics which is the
opposite kind of of economics and the
theories of economics don't include
human beings and their behavior and
their emotions so behavioral economics
is all about how the emotions that we
have
interact with uh you know with economics
to create different
uh outcomes from buying decisions that
would normally be
expected people will rationalize things
based on what they've done before yeah
right so this mental framework around
old things
so if you're trying to create something
new very often you have to relate it to
something
existing
and people can more easily understand
what you're talking about because you
can say oh it's like this
but da da da da da but very often it's
hard for people they don't have a mental
framework or a mental model of how
something already works yeah if you come
in with something really radical and
disruptive they don't know what a place
uh no and so
it's really so much easier like with
pewdiepie
right we're a buyer's club in england
apparently people don't know what a
buyer's club is in america everybody
knows what a buyer's club is right
because there's uh sam's club and
there's uh costco which isn't the same
uh in england as it is in america and
costco in america has like the highest
household income
per customer
yeah because people just pull up in
their range rover and buy you know
everything they sell diamonds at costco
right
but it's always a deal
so
pewdiepie right is kind of like costco
but for luxury cosmetics and skincare
and wellness products and so we source
from all these fantastic labs and we get
the highest quality stuff and then
people can buy it if you're a member of
the club you buy it cheaper than
wholesale
but people in england don't know the
concept so you have to think well it's
kind of like netflix right but but then
you have to actually pay for your
product so it's not really like netflix
so kind of like you know you have to
you're always doing this mental modeling
so that people can understand it really
easily by comparison yeah yeah yeah so
you with bliss you start this business
you move into your own location and then
talk to talk to me about the
the experience of because that was your
first real kind of like business
business employees yes
how was that and scaling that business
until the point when it was it was
acquired fun yeah yeah so i mean it was
a fantastic experience we started quite
small i had a tiny place called let's
face it before i had bliss and i had
probably five employees three rooms so
we had a manicurist we had a
receptionist we had a couple of other
facialists on certain shifts we'd have a
massage therapist come in somebody did
the laundry that wasn't me that was
you know i used to have to take the
laundry out on avenue b i would have to
like carry these huge bags of laundry
from the facials to
avenue a and like do the laundry at
night which was also really crazy if you
think back you could never do this if
you were older this is definitely a 19
20 year olds gig to be working all day
and then going doing laundry on avenue a
and seventh street and you know all
night to get the towels done but
um yeah i opened let's face it first and
had you know probably five six seven
employees and it was great because it
was small enough for me to handle had
like i had no experience with employees
so just understanding the operations of
a business and scheduling and i mean i
really
rate
doing it versus learning about it
and of course i never learned about it
so i never learned how to go structure a
business i never ended up in business
school
i just did it and then i saw the
patterns along the way of what goes
wrong when you do this or what you
should look out for and especially a lot
of patterns with people i think that
you know being able to recognize
patterns
is
a part of
either an emotional intelligence or just
some it's a type of intelligence that's
been very helpful and the older you get
the faster you recognize the patterns
because you've just been around for
longer so and you can see also i'm sure
you've seen those types of people yeah
yeah yeah so you know that type of
person
and you kind of can almost suss people
out after you've spent 10 minutes with
them you kind of know what to expect or
it's kind of what you're describing
earlier but like understanding something
by comparison so i have the same thing
now in business where you and you just
we're talking about there is like you've
done more experiments when you get older
so yeah you can kind of predict the
outcome yeah
that type of person behaves in that type
of way
and when you notice this happening it's
probably because of this and it sounds
like this
you go [ __ ] that
it's like oh no here we go but also i
think there's a
i mean there's a beauty of having it
happen to you over and over and over
again because you realize oh here we go
again when this person does that thing
and it ends like this well the last time
it ended like this well i hired this
person it ended like and it's fine
and so you don't panic as much right
when you're younger and you lose people
who were working for you in your
business you think the world is going to
end
and then you know very often it's just
different when you hire somebody else
right and and usually uh you the the new
person will bring something completely
additive to the table yeah and so it's
actually a good thing but it takes a
long time to get to that point where
when someone's quitting you're going
great
see ya it is
or that you lose sleep over it you know
i rarely will lose sleep anymore if if
uh
someone is going because you always also
think if they're not really thrilled to
be here and and working like at top
level then probably they'll be happier
somewhere else and and that means more
happiness will also come into that spot
and when you're young in business the
story you tell yourself about what that
person quitting means is just deeply
illogical and riddled with like fear and
emotion yes and it's about you it's
personal yes instead of it being about
that yeah yes and uh but when you get
older and you see these good people go
and you know come and go you realize
that it is
an echo system isn't it yeah it's not
awesome it's not a fight you could have
ever win no companies ever managed to
keep 100 of their employees for a
sustained period of time so
um so what how did you get to that point
to exiting the business oh okay so well
epilest so we
we launched bliss in i think july of
2000 oh sorry 1996. so we opened i had
three treatment rooms before that in my
little place called let's face it and i
opened i think nine treatment rooms and
then we put a nap room in in the next
place which was called bliss
and you know back
in the 90s we didn't have there wasn't
social media there wasn't a way to
really get the word out fast unless you
had an article in a magazine
and because that really like moved the
needle oh mike it was a completely
different moment now you get a full page
in new york times right you get traffic
to your website for a day yeah nothing
no nothing because it's so spliced up
right everything is so temporary back
then you got an article in vogue and
your phone rang for 18 months frog yeah
it was so much easier however you had to
be good enough to get an article invoked
so there were a million people doing
what you did but you had to make sure
that the experience that you were
offering was cool enough beautiful
enough desirable that all of your people
were trained well that the results were
good etcetera etcetera and so we were
great right we gave great great service
can i ask you a question on that yeah do
you think service was better back in
those days because there was less
ability to
because what you said there is like you
had to be good enough to get on those
very few big big stages whereas these
days you can kind of ship products and
[ __ ] people can pay to
be seen much easier than they probably
could have back then i'm guessing and
get an endorsement
from a vogue
yeah so is it well it's not sustainable
though is it how many times can you pay
if actually people don't come back more
than once and word of mouth then becomes
your you know starts to bring businesses
still the same right it's all to say
like today is the same it's just split
into different stuff but if you can't
keep that customer for more than one two
three transactions you might as well go
home yeah yeah yeah so you you're
numbered yeah you gotta figure it out at
the beginning like what is going to be
so much better how is going to be that
much better how are you going to deliver
it consistently right make sure that she
is never or he is never disappointed or
they are never right disappointed and
you you have to look at i mean if you
look at acronyms right this ltv to cac
stuff
which i hate thinking of it that way but
because it's humans right yeah it's like
well how many transactions is this
person going to come back for three
years and be a loyal customer and order
stuff from you six times a year or are
they going to order once and go
it has to be pretty compelling
where'd you start with huel and my
recommendation is i think they have a
starter box on the website where you can
get a sample of all the products you
might not like some of the products i
don't love all of the products i'm going
to be completely honest with you i don't
but the ones that i do love
i could now not live without and for me
my starting point was the mixed berry
rtd didn't really like mixing protein
powders before um so i when they had a
ready to drink drink i went for that and
secondly the brand new protein powder
which i've talked about a couple of
times in this podcast now 100 calories
in total
26 of your vitamins and nutrients and it
tastes like a delicious smoothie one
might get from some fast food
establishment but without all the crap
in it give it a shot i don't think
you'll regret it
when you look back at why you were
successful in that business is it
because of that attention to detail oh
yeah in bliss oh my god yes how extreme
are you
so extreme
extreme extreme extreme everything from
how you laid on that table to what the
sheets smelled like to how you bolstered
their knees so that the backs of their
heels when they were lying for a facial
for 60 minutes the backs of their heels
wouldn't ache because their knees were
elevated the right way to the wax that
you put on their hands to how much you
massaged them to
the responses that you would give and we
trained everybody in terms of
the customer says this
it's all about them right it's about
making them feel good not only you know
their face their body whatever you're
treating but mentally right it's not
about you
there are no complaints you don't whine
about anything it's all about making
them thrilled feel great about
themselves look great they should walk
out of there feeling like
we had literally i think the testament
to it when you think back is crazy
loyalty so people come in for their
facials and
say they came in on tuesday night at
seven evenings of course we're always
booked we closed at 10 but so you only
have like a 6 30 to 8 or 8 to 9 30 or
you know you kind of back it up usually
an hour and a half for a facial so
really there were only two evening slots
unless you left work early and then
there were three evening slots 10 rooms
that means you got 30 people in in the
evening
other people they want to come in they
got to like make an excuse to their boss
and come during the day
right or take a day off work to come for
their facial
which people actually did but people
would book their spot
every month for two years
right so that they wouldn't miss it and
if they had to change
they would call and say could you swap
me with somebody else because i don't
want to miss it or they would have a
friend book a different slot and then
they would swap with their friend and so
we had a waiting list
of people who just wanted to come in and
we were booked every day all day for
like probably a year in advance
for those those 10 treatment rooms um
but
we would keep a waiting list and if we
didn't get people in now this is the
date no email right
okay there was not an email i thought
you got your emails one day i was like
no there were no emails okay yeah so you
had the phone and you had your computer
booking system sure but you couldn't
just mass email everybody so we would
literally keep a list of people who were
waiting for appointments and at the end
of each day if we didn't get them in on
a cancellation we call every single one
and apologize
and then tell so at seven o'clock
somebody would start the story calls we
call them the story calls and you were
just the idea was that me
so mike mike you have clearly very very
high standards yes for for detail yeah
how do you police that amongst people
that might not have the same high
standards well they're not my people so
you'd find them
well they would probably be better
elsewhere where their standards were
more aligned with the business that they
were working for i mean bureaucratic
like
well do you i mean you you hire people
then you see if they can operate in your
i mean look if you're the olympic hockey
team
and you've got a goalie who's terrible
they can't stay or you're not going to
win are you so it's not about firing
them it's like is this a team member who
belongs on this team
yeah if i i guess you would say yes you
would fire them you would try how
uncompromising were you about the
standards very uncompromising
i mean we also wrote thank you notes
right so every person who came in for a
treatment whether it was an eyebrow wax
or a manicure or a facial or a massage
the person who did that treatment had to
write a thank you note and it got posted
out that night if you weren't
uncompromising about those standards
those little thank you notes that
apologies you know for the waiting list
well then they knew we were still
thinking about them right so they
thought i have a chance they haven't
forgotten about me and we were grateful
that they were waiting to come in and
pay us money i mean they're giving you a
paycheck aren't they
do you think you'd be sat here now if
you hadn't been uncompromising with the
standards in bliss all those years ago
in 1996 i think you know the answer to
that
of question i wouldn't because it you
know it follows
yeah it compounds you just know what
good looks like and then you know what
people
respond to and that people want to be
treated
you know with respect and you know with
gratitude right your customer you're
handing over your hard-earned money to
somebody
they better be grateful
and
that also keeps you going every day it
just there's so much science about
gratitude and how just starting your day
with thinking wow i'm so lucky
right
i'm thinking about those things that
you're lucky to have i think
i've always operated businesses with
that idea of i am grateful that people
come to me to
buy something or they trust me with
their face
right or they'll get up at seven o'clock
in the morning and pay me 40 to teach
them in aerobics class in their living
room i mean they could be
they could be sponsoring so many other
people but they're sponsoring me and
isn't that so
generous of them if i were to ask you on
that um
if i were to ask you and this is tough
to do in hindsight but i think we're all
capable of doing it
in that period of your life and those
early moments and really throughout your
career
what is it about you that made you
successful i mean i've picked up on one
which is really high standards the other
one i picked up on i picked up on the
minute you walked through the door which
is you're just a very pleasant human
being and i'm like all of these things
if you if they compound over like 30
years you're gonna get to a really good
place but is there anything else within
you know some people are visionaries
they are you know whatever is there
anything else will you say do you know
what that's probably a trait of me that
made me successful yeah i connect the
dots okay in new ways so that if that
were to be kind of my thing yeah it's
about um have you read the book it's
called originals by adam grant yes on
that yeah yeah so someone gave it to me
actually the art teacher in my son's
school
gave it to me and said this sounds like
you
and i read it and i was like oh you know
when you think you're special
yeah yeah
and then you read a book and you're like
nope i'm not special because everybody
he's he's got it down like every chapter
was like oh yeah this is me oh yes this
is me this is me and um he talks about
in the book about how uh
you become an expert in your area right
so you you are very deep in expertise in
one particular area but then you're very
curious about all this other stuff which
is me i scan everything right whether or
not i'm really interested in it i got
newsletters coming out of my eyeballs
and i just kind of scan i'll click on
things and sometimes i'll just force
myself to read something that i have no
interest in at all just because there
might be something in there
um and and i think from doing that
i find new ideas that's what creativity
is isn't it yes i think but you have to
feed it yeah it's like top of funnel mid
funnel bottom of funnel right and so if
you don't have enough top of
you dry up at the bottom where you know
there's nothing that comes through and
then being able to kind of edit a good
idea from a mediocre idea right
yeah but i guess if you come up with a
lot so the more you feed the funnel
then the more stuff you have to look at
and then being able to know which one is
the one that is actually going to
resonate with enough people that it's
actually a business because
a lot of people i think can be quite
navel gazing and i have this idea and
people will care yeah so i can also be
quite brutal with my own ideas and just
go
who cares like you think about it for a
couple of months and then you have to be
able to not fall in love with your own
ideas kind of like with writing so
writers will say
a really great writer is like you can't
fall in love with your own words you
need to be able to go into your writing
and just chop it out right just so it's
succinct and you like you can't love
what you did you have to hate what you
did
and cut it all down so that just the
crispy parts are there and i think it's
the same with ideas you can spend a lot
of time on stuff that nobody cares about
and so you have to be able to edit
so interesting i completely agree i
think about the the successes i've had
in my life and it was just a process of
like multiple sources from multiple
disciplines
pull one little dot as you said from
those different disciplines and then
when they come together so it could be
like cryptocurrencies music and my
knowledge of social media and then you
come together and you go oh together it
makes something new and interesting and
valuable as a these three different
points of inspiration um i was going to
ask you the question when we were
talking about that i was like can you
teach someone in your experience to be
better at thinking of good ideas i think
you can provide the
uh environment okay right but not
everyone's going to be able to do that
so there is going to be a cohort of
people who just don't think of new ideas
and they're probably really good at
other things and that's okay because the
world needs all of them right um like
switzerland like they you know some
people are plumbers but they still make
100 grand a year and everybody's happy
so if we put people in the right seats
on the bus there's such a
position and that of course is
management isn't it it's trying to find
when someone has talent but not in a
particular area you make sure they're
doing the right thing
um
but i think you can
you see this a lot in business school
not that i've been there but i've sat on
a lot of panels with people who are
who are entrepreneurs right and they're
entrepreneurs because they have
done a business plan and they've done a
business model they've modeled out what
if what you know we can do this they
haven't
come up with oh wait just like you said
if i connect this and this and do it
this way or right then i can make this
happen they've they've said well i've
gone to harvard and now i'm going to
model out this business plan and i think
if we do this and that we can make oh
look it's a profit yeah yeah
and so
there's two ways to come by it and i
guess both are valid and especially
these days um the
there's so much money in the universe
that people will invest in so many
things that you could actually get to uh
a good result by just putting a business
plan down you're having tons of money
and having gone to harvard which is much
easier to get money yes
and silicon valley and being a white
male all that kind of stuff yeah um so
it works yeah yeah
is it full of passion yeah
i don't know maybe if you're passionate
about making money that's a passion it's
not my way to do it because i just have
to be passionate about whatever it is
i'm making or selling or
you know whatever i think i'm improving
if it's improving people's existence
then i'm passionate about it
and there was like so
amazing to be at bliss and have people
coming in and walk out the door after
their treatment feeling like
so happy and you could see it right and
they just had
such a great time and you thought well
i'm responsible for that and what a
great thing to do all day and then the
same with pewdiepie right is
wow
people open up these boxes that they get
delivered and it is like
it's like a fairy tale yeah and it
didn't cost them much so they can treat
themselves because everybody needs a
little lift once in a while and to be
able to get this incredibly deluxe stuff
for such a an affordable price you know
every time one of those boxes opens up
that somebody is just feeling thrilled
and that
is a reason to like show up in the
morning right yeah yeah
yeah one of them sounds like a really
sustainable fulfilling intrinsically
driven journey and the other one sounds
a bit like yeah like you know the
pursuit of trying to get rich which is
it's harder to sustain quite honestly
because
the hard days on the heart i was going
to say you know it gets excruciatingly
difficult yeah so one day there's going
to be many days that it you'd probably
quit if you weren't just truly just
living for fast yeah yeah regardless of
remuneration but speaking of money
you sell bliss at some point yeah so in
1999 we had quite a few um interested
buyers is that three years after yeah
that's quick we were great
selling the company three years later
you know yeah at my at the age i was it
was quite hilarious
i would have been 30 super young yeah 30
when we sold it uh so i sold 70 to lvmh
that's nuts it was nuts you know we had
a few different
large cosmetic conglomerates kind of
circling around yeah um
one came in and gave me a big
presentation and they had champagne
ready and we're talking about how they
put me in a studio by myself and i could
just be creative you know this you're
talking to a girl who does facials and
waxes people's legs do i want to go
to a studio by myself i mean my favorite
thing was knowing i'd look at my list of
who was coming in that day and it was
like oh i get to see this person this
person
that the joy was all the people right so
they oh we're going to give you a loft
right and then we had another one who
came in and said we want to turn your
spot into a spa under this brand name
which i thought what why would you buy
it if you yeah
um and then there was lvmh who flew me
to paris on the concorde no they didn't
yes they did and took me out for lunch
you know it was it was quite fabulous
though i have to admit it wow and it was
hilarious when i got back to brooklyn
when i flew back from paris on the
concord and it was the middle of the
west indian day parade in brooklyn so
i'm in a taxi from the airport going
back to the spa although it was a
holiday day
and i was going we had redone the floors
and i was going just to make sure that
everything was dry and move the
furniture back into the place so i'm
i'm on the subway because i couldn't get
a taxi to take me all the way in because
the west indian day parade was blocking
flatbush avenue and i was on the subway
going towards my print street stop and
there was
coke spilled all over it not coke but
you know like
yeah coca-cola spilled all over the
seeds and drunk people everywhere and
i'm standing there going i want to find
the only person on this subway who was
on the concrete this morning
i thought you probably probably all
those other people are in their car
services no it was pretty funny so
anyway they
were the most interesting they loved the
business we were kind of hot at the time
they were looking for american
acquisitions i think they had moved
sephora also into america at the time so
they thought it would be kind of a good
partnership and
and you know the price was right and i
thought well i've been starving for
since i moved to new york right
every month it was kind of like do i
have enough money to pay the rent
blindly yeah and i just thought well
is this gonna happen again you don't
know you don't know if you'll ever be
offered like a a big chunk of change
like that so and you 100 own the company
at this point yeah yeah so you and you
didn't raise money outside capital they
bought 70 percent of the business for
tens of millions yes so right yes
unbelievable yeah i know i mean you
could have just stopped there right you
could have just stopped there and oh my
god with 30 what what are you going to
do no i'm i'm a hypocrite because i
yeah yeah you're not going to just stop
where you're going to go like stand at
your fridge all day but i mean most
people will just land that one big bag
in their life if they're lucky if
they're extremely lucky and in the
minority but then you went again and you
created a business called soap and glory
which people know in this country yeah
it was big silver glory was big
at the time you know it was um
if i was i was reading a lot of
newspapers
and there was a lot of collaborating
going on between kind of designer brands
and
you know the high street
and i thought wouldn't it be fun just to
kind of make a really great brand um
that has we couldn't do at drugstore
prices you can't really do
high quality
like super high quality product
and sell it
at a drugstore price when you're going
through the retail food chain because
there's all the markups right so you you
had to try and make really like
i'd say i won't say high quality but
good quality products for a price point
and make them really fun and i just
thought you know what let me try doing
something that's using all the puns i'm
a bit of a writer
so i love to write copy and so it was
all about making the products kind of
fun and you know good quality for just
the right price to kind of you know be
mass
and i launched in harvey nichols and it
was actually quite a good success but
harvey nichols only has
nice bridge and then a few other stores
around the country and i knew i wasn't
going to be able to make much of a
splash just being in harvey nichols on a
few shelves um so boots came to us and
said you know would you like to roll out
into different boots doris that was
really interesting because i thought
this is going to be amazing oh my god
we're going to go into boots we're going
to make like millions
and i remember i think we were in
300 boot stores and you just for some
reason you just think okay if it's in
boots right every brand you see in boots
you think oh they're making a fortune
yeah um and i remember we launched and i
think that
the first
week
i think we did three hundred dollars
yeah and then i couldn't figure out why
so i go into my local boots and it's on
the bottom shelf
and so that was they don't reset the
shelves for 10 months
okay so you start just thinking oh my
god i'm gonna be making 300
a week
for 10 months until they reset the
shelves and i fight my way to the top
i need to get back into just the gap
there in that period though when you've
left bliss and you're you're not doing
anything now you have a lot of money so
you don't really need to worry about the
bills or the rent anymore anything like
that i just i'm just intrigued because
i've took a month off okay one month
yeah
it wasn't enough that's not a long time
it wasn't enough it wasn't enough i took
six months between my last sale and
figuring out what to do next six months
was better
one month
one month so in that one month what are
you doing you're doing i went on holiday
to the south of france okay so you're on
holiday to france then you come back and
you're just
straight into it yeah yeah just you know
ideas i mean i always have ideas so i'll
be walking down the street i'll get an
idea so you kind of jot them down and
then the ones that keep bubbling up to
the surface those are the good ones i
love i love this i read about i read
about you talking about this because i
it rang so true to me because we all
people like you and um creative people
generally will get and you i yeah i
don't want to get myself into i'm trying
to be humble here um people will get
lots of ideas a lot of the time and the
process in which you decide which one to
go is and which ones should just be
disregarded um i find fascinating and
i've only been able to understand
it um in hindsight why i pick certain
ideas and why i just let other ones go
but how do you filter out the ones that
are worth pursuing and the ones aren't
okay so there's something i call the so
what test okay
so you ask yourself
so what
tell yourself your idea and then ask
well so what and if you cannot
explain why you would want to do that or
why anybody should care in one sentence
it's not a good enough idea nice yeah
but you also let them sit for a while
right yeah because there's so many you
have to the ones that are just sort of
average they just they go away right and
the good ones kind of stay at the top
and you think i've got to do that i've
got to do that that's really good i
would buy that of course here's the
other cheat right
i only sell stuff that i would buy
so i can't you know it would be
difficult for me
if i'm trying to create a business
centered around something that i don't
want or have a need for i don't know if
i would be as good at it
super easy to do beauty pie because i
love beauty products i love candles i
love supplements i know all the good
labs i've worked with them for 30 years
i know where to get the good stuff i'm
gonna buy it anyway
i would like to buy the high quality
stuff
i don't want to have to pay retail
okay
so obvious that one right with flip flop
it was i could not find a pair of shoes
that actually
felt comfortable on my feet and i love
you know i love uh fashion
i can't believe how many businesses
you've started and how many of them have
done so well
it's not that many it isn't i have one
more i have one more but it's not i
can't tell you i'll kill you
can't be super duper
yeah that also oh you forgot about that
one yeah but but actually that one is
taking a of us because our supplier shut
down during covid
and so it was yeah well it's still
around except our supplier shut down and
so we have to re-formulate everything so
soap and glory is a business that even i
know and i'm not you know yeah you're
not a cosmetics guy well you know well
uh because at christmas
[Music]
oh maybe you'll be a you can be a
pewdiepie beauty guy yeah but now i know
the brand yeah it's a well very very
well known brand so because we used to
take over
that week before christmas at boots we
would literally have hundreds of
thousands of those big pink bags that
people would be able to buy for a really
crazy deal
that was also i guess a learning just
seeing how much people love a deal
um and every it was almost every year
that we would be this sort of christmas
bumper
bag i would see women leaving boots with
like three on each arm because they were
buying them for all of their friends
when you think of that business why was
it successful
and um
what was your what's your sort of
emotional memory recollection and memory
of that phase of your life
um gosh that's a
another deep question one of these
questions yeah okay so well emotional
recollection i mean it was great to be
able to build something new it was great
to be able to build something that was
popular in a different country
right so you didn't just do it in
america you also could do it in the uk
like ronaldo yeah
maybe i'm not so good with the ball but
um it was exciting to do something math
like at mass price points because you
could reach more people so more people
could afford
the joy that you were trying to bring
through that product so that's always
really nice because having something
that's only affordable
well i love high quality things the
exclusion
of people that comes along with a luxury
price point
i don't like so much right so the idea
of luxury for
affordable of course is is the also the
holy grail um so building
it was you know building soap and glory
was also a real experience in terms of
learning how to deal with a
retailer who really had a monopolistic
grip on
a country right because boots was the
power you know be all powerful
and so that was a real learning curve
how big did soap and glory get
i think we sold
we were selling probably 100 plus
million dollars of the stuff a year
through boots
[ __ ] that's a lot of money it was not
bad it was it was biggest it was big
yeah it was big i mean it could could be
it could have been bigger could have
been bigger
it was great for me i i don't you know
what's the difference between like 50
100 100 weeks
yeah you just it's like after you can
pay your rent and eat and buy as many
t-shirts as you need
you know your life doesn't change that
much right but you want to
you want to bring out more and see how
much you can do and see if you can offer
even yeah better stuff so you sold that
business two booths yeah in uh 2014.
2014 not so long ago it really wasn't
yeah no
seven years yeah
yeah they really wanted it and how did
you feel when you when you you know they
made the offer you accept the offer did
it feel again like the was it was there
a loss of orientation in your life
no because oh here we go yeah well at
the same time i have flip flop right
okay so my footwear brand is also big
ish
uh you know 65 countries we sell a lot
of shoes could be bigger
and it's going to be bigger
um and yeah and so i sort of had one
thing to still grip onto and to really
focus on and to make sure that that
quality and and dream about what kind of
product we're going to produce for the
next season it's all kind of the same
right as product development and then
rolling it out and trying to learn you
know given that feedback loop that you
get from from the product that you're
launching
remarkable
um your partner is also an entrepreneur
yes yeah he does now costa rican um
ecotourism
how is that working with uh not working
with how is it to
have a partner that's also in
the field of entrepreneurship because
you know what it is i'm gonna ask you a
question here because i'm super curious
maybe you can help me i've always
wondered if as an entrepreneur it would
make more sense to be with an
entrepreneur or someone that just does
nothing sits at home just you know yep
being there yeah exactly
well it depends i suppose on your
appetite for risk and if you have risk
anymore
right so if you've already managed to
um you know sell something and you have
a little bit of money in the bank then
having two people going out there and
risking it all
is okay because you have something to
fall back on i think certainly having a
partner who understands what you're
going through day to day and will
listen to you you know we talked about
being able to see someone
it's so important to have someone who
sees you
and who can understand what it might be
like for you on a day that's really hard
and offer you that kind of support
my husband is great with that like he
i couldn't ask for somebody who supports
me more and he does the stuff that i you
know necessarily don't want to do in
terms of that family stuff and we pick
up the the uh different um
programs i suppose really beautifully
together because he'll take care of some
stuff and i take care of other stuff and
and when you come home
are you good at sort of
compartmentalizing the work stuff and
then like switching off and
being present with
family maybe not always i appreciate the
honesty
i don't know if you can be right because
sometimes work is really interesting
also right so i've got two teenage boys
and they sometimes come out of their
rooms
i'm not
and so sometimes i'll be on social media
chatting with customers right giving
them advice telling what to use on their
skin it's actually it's quite social as
it is social media
uh i go home
at night because i'm hoping they will
come out of their rooms and i can spend
time with them but
we have dinner and then they usually go
wanna you know play video games because
all their friends are on video games so
if they do come out of their room you
know at some point
i might be in the middle of something am
i really good at just turning that off
and saying i am here for you young man
not always
sometimes but sometimes what i'm doing
is actually more interesting than
talking about the basketball game that
you know the nba blah blah blah or
whatever it is and i'm maybe not the
best at switching attention gears but
i'm trying
and i'm mindful of it yeah yeah
is it something that you you think you
want to be better at yes absolutely yes
more of that in the moment
right really trying to live just that
moment there's a great podcast have you
ever listened to making sense with sam
harris
yes once or twice i'm a big sam harris
fan me too yeah so it's you know it is
about okay you're here right now and
live it and
and if you could live every moment over
again because you only get one shot he
you know how he has those little daily
there's like a little daily thing that
pops up and you can listen to and he was
talking once about how
you have one opportunity to live this
moment
and you have one opportunity to have an
interaction with someone that is this
interaction
like make it good
right and just thinking well i can
either
you know
look at this as an opportunity and a
gift
or i can be down and negative about it
and you just choose
so i try
as much as possible to choose even if i
have you know cranky teenagers or
whatever work thing going on to choose
to really
be positive about the fact that i'm
given the opportunity to live that
moment do you ever worry
that um you'll regret being so busy
and
missing certain things always don't you
yeah i do yeah of course yeah especially
with the kids
once with my parents a lot i think god
my parents are getting old and
i think i was i'm i'm gonna at some
point i'm gonna keep it facts my parents
gonna die and i'm going to think to
myself i wish i would have spent more
time with them yeah the death bed test i
literally wrote down the death bed test
in my notes yeah i want to ask you about
that tell me about the death bed test oh
the deathbed test is like what are you
going to
on your deathbed
think back and go god i wish i would
have done more of that or i wish i would
have tried this or we should have tried
that
and so if you live this actually was
something that i think her name was tina
johnson she was the ceo of saks fifth
avenue i remember having a meeting with
her and she said you know what i just
always use the death bed test it's like
i don't want to miss my kids
you know this particular event or
ceremony right you will kick yourself
if you miss the grade 5 graduation that
that is always going to be more
important than your conversion rate yeah
i wrote an article actually called
deathbed thinking which is quite strange
when i when i saw that you you had this
thing called the death bed test and it
was inspired by brony bronywere who was
the palestinian in australia who okay
people as they're about to die yeah and
what they wish they would have yeah done
with their lives have you seen also on
social media going around i think i've
seen it on instagram but you see um some
elderly people and they're taking
pictures of them with like yeah what is
your advice right and it's always very
simple be nice to everybody obvious
stuff yeah yeah yeah
but you just think well yeah cause you
gotta live with yourself and and it's
the deathbed test looking back on it but
actually your deathbed test
sam harris would say is probably taking
place every moment of your waking
existence right i wish i would have been
more polite i wish him because if you're
not
you have to then live with how you feel
about yourself and that
is more important than anything
so
this is a mini a micro deathbed test
taking place every moment i would argue
quick one as a serial entrepreneur
that's currently building multiple
projects across multiple industries
everything from the marketing industry
to blockchain to consumer goods
everything one of the things that has
been a lifesaver for me and again a
company that i reached out to to
evangelize about on this podcast because
i'm a loyal customer and they ultimately
ended up sponsoring this podcast is
fiverr.com f i v e r r what that site
allows me to do is extend my capacity
across all of my projects if i'm looking
for a graphic designer someone to edit a
video someone to do a website for me it
allows me to extend my capacity without
hiring people and the quality of
freelancers on fiverr has been amazing
and when the the trust and the service
you get is that phenomenal and the
services offered are that diverse it's a
no-brainer whether you have one member
of staff you're a freelancer yourself or
a thousand members of staff five it can
be a game changer for you and i'd love
you guys to check it out use the link
below go to fiverr.com
ceo
and send me a screenshot if you end up
using the service
i was looking at a couple of things that
you'd said and one of them was about
your motto for life which is about
choosing yourself
and not waiting for anybody
yeah what does that mean well you know
you can wait around for someone to tell
you that you're the one who can do it
or it's your turn or you can just
do it yourself right you're the one who
is going to tell you that you can do
something no one is going to pick you
out of a line and say hey go
you have to put yourself out there so
i remember i have this fantastic friend
his name's emilio sosa and he actually
worked when he was a budding fashion
designer and in new york a long time ago
and he worked at the front desk at bus
for a while
and it was just his you know like actors
would work at a restaurant he was like
the cool guy at the front desk at bliss
and um
and he designed a few ranges and you
know they weren't always commercially
successful but he was just the coolest
person around
and i remember
i lost touch with him for a little while
you know a few years because he stopped
working at the spa and when i found him
again somehow because again this is
pre-email right i found him and he came
over for dinner and he i said so what
are you up to and he said oh i'm
designing costumes for winter marsalis
and i've been on tour with celine dion
and blah blah blah blah right
and i said emilio like what happened and
he said you know what
i woke up one day and i just thought i
am worthy
and that was it right like that was the
moment it moved for him he just had to
decide
that he was talented and worthy of all
of this success and then he had it
and i think it's the same for so many
people that they just
aren't convinced
now
you might just be born convinced i see
some people who are born convinced right
and they don't necessarily have the
experience of the merit to back it up
and then there's some people who've just
worked for it and after you do that much
work and you are you know that your
expertise is at a level where you
actually
are convinced because
evidence you've got evidence and then
this when you're on the cusp
right where you just have to decide so
that you can get more
uh practice
to become
that one but at some point
you know you're on that fence you've got
to decide
and then you take yourself there so
that's absolutely
bad because when you were describing
your different business ventures there
was a moment when you described your
clients moving to the hamptons for the
summer and like business drops off a
little bit and you you said so casually
so i decided to go and do a beauty
course to find out how my like that
moment i think is probably the most
pivotal difficult special moment because
you made it a decision yes in a new
direction yes that is like it sounds so
simple the way you just like gloss past
it i was thinking that's pretty profound
very few everyone gets stuck in what
they do yeah it seems and the certainty
of this the comfortable certainty of
that wherever they are to make just make
the decision one day that i'm gonna go
do a beauty course to find out why
acne skin is the way it is and see if i
can do something about it is
is the for me the pivotal unique thing
yeah that's actually you know good
observation yeah i was going to stop you
on it but you just glided past it so i
never thought of it that way but you're
right it's like almost how dare you i'm
like people don't do that
they don't you do when you're 20
right
they don't well listen from what i've
read listened heard etc that the new
skill that everyone's gonna have to have
is not to be identified by what you were
doing for the last 10 years because
there's so many there's so many jobs
right so many careers that will just be
gone and so we have to train
the next gen
who's coming up to not think well i'm
this labels yeah you have to be ready to
say well that doesn't exist anymore i'm
going to pivot or i have to go get
retrained and not have your identity
completely
wrapped up in what you do right it's
more about your ability to
morph and learn and so being this
lifelong learner
is so important when you think about
yourself going forward now you know
you've got you're working on multiple
businesses at the moment beauty pipe
being your main event i believe yeah um
what is it what is it you're playing for
now because you know you've got the
money you've got the reputation you've
got wonderful family what are you
playing for now
well happiness and stimulation right and
how do you get that it's a it's a
community
i have a small family so we're four and
then i don't have two sisters and my mom
and then extended you know cousins who i
don't really connect with that much
because they're in western canada
um and so for me being able to have this
community of people
who okay yes they happen to shop from me
but they're quite fun and most of our
customers are of the same spirit it's
like having hundreds of thousands of
friends
and so they're out there chatting about
the latest thing it's just it's like a
social club a little bit and we happen
to all buy beauty products and be really
excited when the next thing is launching
so
i've read a quote once it said like for
people who have multiple marriages it's
like the first time you marry for love
the second time is for money and the
third time is for companionship
and so i'm probably on companionship but
i want to do it really well
because it is you know
it's a lot of fun to be able to
provide this to so many people
and that love that you get back from it
if you're doing it well is
you know quite a nice uh quite nice
feeling to
to have every day so is this your
forever business
um
that's a really great question i don't
think i never think of things in
you know forever really big check over
there in the drawer
it would have to be really billion
dollars not big enough
okay i mean listen it's just fun right
it's fun to create it's fun to create so
i i don't really think about it as
what's the end of this right if i if i
find okay actually i've created all the
stuff i know how to create and now i can
i don't know i'm just chatting with the
people but you know how businesses go
through different stages where different
skill sets are needed i'm not your
typical like great operating person i
need to find that person i'm not a
performance marketing person i need to
find that person and at some stage
you don't need as much of what i do you
need more of what they do and so it
depends like how much do do they need me
um but i i think just keeping that
quality very high is is always something
that you need a particular personality
to be leading so i think that's where it
would be hard to replace what i do i
think what you've achieved is i mean
it speaks for itself it's quite um hard
to believe in fact that in one lifetime
someone could have so many back-to-back
successes um i've had a few flops well
yeah i know and i heard you talk about
that i heard you say you know the key to
success was failure but i've not heard
you talk about any failures yet right
because i i think i um
i i compartmentalize them i learn from
them and then i move past them
there's no point in wallowing um but i
do think it's really important and it's
funny a lot of people will come to me
and ask for mentorship
and i'll do my best in the time that
i've got available but uh
what i really think has been my own
mentor has been failure
and
and looking at the feedback that you get
from that failure and kind of
internalizing it and it becoming part of
your dna and i really believe that if
you don't fail yourself someone telling
you that you might fail is not the same
as failing
yeah that
you know you just have to fail once
really hard and you're not going to make
that mistake again did you fail once
really hard um i don't know how hard is
hard you know
my it's sort of like my appetite for
risk people say well that's so risky i'm
like what
so can you think of something when
you're when you're talking about failure
that you've failed really hard yeah
i mean yeah i mean sure we did at soap
and glory we did a men's range it didn't
really sell
okay just test
yeah well yeah whatever you know was the
price wrong was the packaging the wrong
color
it just didn't fly do men really not use
that many cosmetics that they're gonna
did they just use their their partner's
stuff who knows but it was an a b test
it didn't knock the wind out of sales no
rarely do does the wind get knocked out
of my sales because again
when you're i think when you're young
and you have a
profound loss
you take everything with relativity
right it's like okay so what
so
you know people didn't buy soap and
glory men's products but
does it really matter on my deathbed
will i even remember that i did that
probably not so
you can put it into perspective which is
do you think your father's passing has
helped you put all of the decisions
later in your life into perspective and
prioritize them differently oh yeah
absolutely yes i think uh any kind of uh
you know grief or really emotional
situation that you go through you become
a different person and you can relate to
other people
who have the same situation or have you
know
a difficult home situation in a a very
quick way because they see the world in
a similar way that you do that small
things don't really matter
and so while we're all doing a lot of
small things to kind of push the world
along every day that they're not really
that important in the end people
watching this you know there'll be a lot
of people that are in all of you and
they'll think you're incredibly awesome
right rightfully so and that can be
somewhat alienating right because they
can see that what you've achieved in
your life and because of your
awesomeness they'll think
you know i can't she's just too far away
from me i'm never gonna be able to get
get to where she is um so what advice
would you give to those people that are
that want to you know achieve great
things in their career in terms of
where they should start where they
should where their journey should
naturally begin
in order to um achieve great things and
become successful subjectively whatever
that means to them oh that's a great
question i think listen i was started
very hands-on right i literally gave
facials nine times a day waxed people's
legs and it's the feedback loop and
being open
to learning
so i'm a real believer of hands-on
training i'm not of course i never had a
business school training so i don't know
i can't compare and contrast but i know
that the confidence that comes with
learning and perfecting a skill
and being able to do it yourself so that
if for instance some member of your team
up and leaves you can take over that and
do that um there's a real confidence in
it and that confidence kind of allows
you to
grow
and um and to put more things underneath
you and to feel
i think more generous with your spirit
so
just rolling your sleeves up and
learning skills as many as you can and
looking without defensiveness at the
feedback that you're getting from
whatever it is that you're doing and
then always asking yourself
how can i improve this how can i make
this even better is this the kind of
feedback that i'm trying to get it's a
giant a b test right so life is kind of
an a b test and if you look at what
works and keep doing more of that and
less of the other right it's about
making like more good decisions than bad
and
i'm being honest with yourself and
yeah it comes down to something
very basic you you treat your customers
like you would want to be treated and i
don't know if that always
floats to the top yeah um for for people
in business and and for large
corporations it is
always being about obsessed with
whatever that product is that you're
trying to deliver and making sure that
you yourself would buy it for the price
that you're selling it and feel thrilled
and whatever you're doing right
you can do it well if you keep those
kinds of things in mind
amen
well listen thank you so much for your
time and i've taken so much of it but
it's been so inspiring so unbelievably
inspiring and i'm so um i understand the
audience that listened to the podcast
and and what you've um shared today is
just gonna be of just tremendous
tremendous value so thank you so much um
you super inspire me i feel like i need
to go for a run or something or
like i don't know i find something to
improve on but uh um yeah just
incredibly incredibly inspiring and you
are such a wonderful delightful bright
light so um thank you and it's been a
super big pleasure to sit here with you
today thank you this is like the feel
good society
that's your experience i've learned i'm
trying to make my customers feel good
yeah this is very good i applaud you
well done thank you so much thanks for
having me
[Music]
oh
[Music]